o que mais precisamos Em momento como o
que estamos vivendo é emprestar nossa
voz nossos corações nossa mente e nossa
criatividade para criar soluções ganha
ganha ganha e no mundo que funcione para
todos que mais precisamos aprender a
viver dentro dos limites planetários já
violamos vários limites já causamos
mudanças climáticas perigosas Estamos
chegando perto de desencadear simples
desgovernados no sistema climático que
pode ter efeitos catastróficos para toda
a humanidade a
e até 2030 teremos um clima mais antes
filme e algumas previsões que podemos
chegar a 120 milhões de refugiados
climáticos que mais precisamos é criar
soluções e ações e tenho a capacidade de
manter e regenerar funções saudáveis dos
ecossistemas com base na verdadeira
riqueza e bem-estar para todos o que
mais precisamos é que nossos sistemas
econômicos mudem do crescimento
quantitativo para o qualitativo
revitalizando as economias locais e
regionais através de prosperidade e vem
da colaboração o que mais precisamos é
saber que tudo está radicalmente
desconectar o que você faz afeta a todo
o planeta se ouvíssemos essa frase
alguns meses atrás pensaremos em algo
como um conceito filosófico né e nos
faltariam
com pratos caseiros em mas agora faz
todo sentido entender que a ação de uma
pessoa do outro lado do mundo pode
impactar entanto os pais temos hoje o a
oportunidade de ouro para fazer uma
grande virada na Regeneração em nosso
planeta percebe que basta para um pouco
e a natureza começa a se regenerar mas a
pergunta que fica é como posso amar este
mundo todo dia um pouco mais
o cardápio como estamos falando de mudar
o quanto anos consumir menos menos roupa
- eletrônicos fazer manutenção para
gente ir nos catar o que ainda pode ser
utilizado ter compaixão por todos os
seres que vivem E viveram no planeta
podemos também começar a falar sobre as
árvores que você sabe sobre ela que elas
vivem paradas em algum lugar algumas
flores ferida do Frutos outras apenas
com as suas folhagens algumas baixas
outras altas enormes né algumas que
vivem há décadas outra Centenários
algumas naturalmente solitárias enquanto
outras só conseguem viver se fizerem
parte de uma comunidade e assim como
nossa cada uma se adaptar melhor a
determinada a mente É acho que temos
muito a aprender
e como com as florestas com as águas e
contou descer com sistemas somos
imprescindíveis para a manutenção na
vida da terra que nossas terras férteis
e Nossas ações conscientes possam brotar
o Futuro que Queremos
E aí